foreign
Colorado Springs hi Lindsay welcome to
the Ramsey Show
and Rachel hey what's up
so my husband and I are looking for your
guidance related to the costs that we're
paying to our financial advisor for
managing our growing retirement
portfolio how much are you trying to
find out
um well we're we've we've had a lot of
conversations related to this so we're
at .87
yearly but when we look at the impact of
a growing portfolio and compounding
interest we're not we're wanting to make
sure that we're being good stewards and
that there's value for those fees that's
a normal managed fund or managed amount
for million dollar account
so if it grows above a million dollars
do you end up with I mean it should be
it should be discipline it should be
going down
um I mean if you want to shop it around
but they're not ripping you off that's
that's a fairly standard way managed
accounts are how almost all Brokers are
handling it now they used to sell mutual
funds on commission
and and now they just plump them in
there and manage the whole thing on a
managed account uh I would say 90
something percent of our smart investor
Pros use that exact system
uh now it could it be that you know
what's the size of your portfolio
million you said
oh it's only 500 000 right now oh you're
fine I have 20 working years and so we
were just looking at you know what would
Dave say you've obviously got you know a
multi-million dollar portfolio like are
we doing the best we should do we get
the value is there you know do you want
to have that managed or is there a
better way to do it yeah most uh uh most
of our Ramsay personalities most of the
people in the building are doing that
with one of our smart investor Pros
exactly that way my personal portfolio
was set up before that stuff came on and
it's old school and so and I don't ever
buy or sell I just buy and hold so
there's not a lot of management to it so
I've never moved it personally into that
but it's not because it's a rip-off it's
not because we hate it it's not that at
all it's just mine was Antiquated and I
just there's no point in doing it
because I don't do anything with it it
just sits there so but I I think that
you know again
the most the folks in this building a
George camel I suspect a Rachel Cruz I
don't know those kinds of folks are
they're paying a managed fee with one of
our smart investor pros and it's
probably right at about that same amount
now it is fair for you to ask what the
flip they're doing to earn that
you know it's fair to go okay if if you
are you just sitting here looking at it
and it just not I mean what are we
getting for our one percent you know
that's a fair question it's not like you
and I don't suggest you do a bunch of
buying and selling so you know I don't
want there to I I really big on just
buying and keeping it unless there's a
real reason to get out of the fund when
Lindsay the the person managing it for
you guys just do they sit down and look
at your entire Financial picture at all
like is that or is it just specifically
just investing because our smart
investor Pro I mean we sit down we look
at basically everything which is just so
helpful like that's one reason I love
having somebody we sit down every
January and it's everything from
investing to looking at kids college to
even giving purposes of stuff that they
like they just know that world some
estate planning yeah they just I mean in
your case actually your guy called out a
really good Capital thing capital gains
thing on a piece of real estate yeah we
had our our house when we moved we kept
it for a rental but then we were going
to sell it and it was a capital gains
thing so yeah he just like gave us
information I was like oh yeah that's
right okay so it's just having somebody
in your corner so you don't have that
but you have but you have estate
planning with attorney I mean all that
stuff but I'm saying you have you have
people in your corner well I've got him
in my corner I mean I just don't pay him
a monthly fee yeah I mean I'll pay him
an annual fee because I bought the funds
and paid the commissions up front right
shares right they're called and so uh
and I've already paid the deal and it's
just sitting there and again I haven't
sold a mutual fund in probably 20 years
I just buy them
you know I just died my I have no
activity on my account at all except
purchases so it's just not a thing so
but I think it's a great conversation
and I would sit down I will tell you
that the vast majority of quality uh
financial planner types broker types and
financial advice people managing helping
you with your retirement accounts those
kinds of things are set up on exactly
that plan there's a few people that
still do only a shares a lot of people
will only do that plan now because the
of liability that they take on under the
federal erisa rules and so forth if they
don't do that plan but uh but I I it is
a great conversation to have and say why
are you worth one percent why would I
not just buy this on my own and not give
you 0.87 or one or whatever it is right
but but you're not out of line you're
not getting ripped off I wouldn't be
panicking about it but you're very wise
to start out to be always asking these
questions a you need to understand your
Investments and B you need to understand
anything you're being charged and what
are you getting for what you're being
charged I think those are wonderful now
I will tell you this everybody out there
not not you Lindsay because I don't
think that's going on with you but
there again
there's these all there's these little
nuanced pieces of research studies that
are done the people that do not have a
broker like that in their corner are
unbelievably more likely to pull their
money out every time there's bad news
and to put pull their money at exactly
the wrong time and buy at exactly the
wrong time trying to time the market so
if you never pull your money out it's
worth 0.87 just to keep you from jumping
off the cliff just to talk you off the
ledge just to talk you off the ledge
because you're having a broker in your
corner goes don't do that here's the
historical data here's what happens you
know every year following a two-year
downturn except one since the 1930s
we've seen a huge uptick we've had two
down years we're going to see a huge
uptick historically coming up most
people don't know that but if you've
studied the charts and you know what the
mutual fund returns are you know what
stock market returns are you know that
and you're a broker and you're advising
people you can talk them off the ledge
and go you're getting ready to get out
at exactly the wrong time I know it's
been flat I know it's been sucky we've
you know we're in an inflationary Biden
economy it's horrible out there life's
not good I get that but just hang on the
Sun is going to come up tomorrow and
they talk you off that ledge and you're
getting ready to bail at exactly the
wrong time yep and and so that that
having that broker in your corner to
bounce stuff off of or occasionally
bring you some emotion out of it yeah
yeah bring you a different idea or a
different way of looking at something
not constantly buying and selling the
account though
now that you we don't want to do that
but just to just to have somebody there
that's walking with you in the you know
got your best interest at heart because
they make money only when you do
um and and you know that that's if the
thing if the whole thing goes down in
value they make less so that that's not
a bad way to incentivize them but you
know it's it is a great thing back to
her original point to ask and understand
always know why you're being charged and
what you're getting for what you're
being charged